I've been making this drink sound so
attractive and desirable for all these
years do you recognize me
I'm the kool-aid man oh yeah so I've had
several people say it's hard to picture
that that voice is actually coming from
you the human being oh yeah I like the
voice because they don't know who I am
when I first auditioned I think they
wanted to get the flavor of the kool-aid
man that was already on the air when I
came in instead of making it oh oh oh oh
so he's gotta have a big deep voice so I
just start like this guy wants to be a
oh yeah cool and I tried to make their
voice uh you know just kind of roll
around gutturally in my throat oh yeah I
can remember those sessions after three
hours of them just saying okay do it
again do it again do it again try it
again
how about lower more energy more of this
more Barry White bigger bigger bigger
louder louder everything like what what
am I not doing that you're not getting
but you're telling me to use a lot of
high energy like David Lee Roth I said
the two don't mix David Lee Roth's going
oh yeah doesn't mix with Barry White
going oh yeah so what you have to find a
happy balance
bottoms up hmm
people make assumptions all the time
so let's get the record straight if I
was a drug addict
how could I possibly have done all this
I'm Lisa Frank and this madness that you
see and all this excitement started with
me I know that you weren't comfortable
being on camera is there an element to
the secrecy
well the secrecy has worked for so long
like well I come out of the closet I
don't want to disappoint anybody what if
I'm not who they want me to be
our look is really been consistent for
30 years and people have tried to tell
me bright colors are in you should do
pastels and it's not who I am who we are
entering the vault that has all the
original our Guinness okay I better
figure out how to open it before you
film it the room is fireproof so that we
don't lose the original art look how
bright everything still is we were
involved in the big sticker craze in the
80s then it went to school supplies
because sticker is an inch to three
inches so it was more fun to get the art
bigger and you can see it says library
sample do not remove that means like
it's probably one of a kind in hindsight
we could have been even smarter like
keeping 12 of everything there are some
things I don't even have it was so
exciting because we were onto something
that no one else was really on to I mean
people thought I had horns coming out of
my head when I would suggest things
early on the buildings more than 300,000
square feet and at one time like every
Bay was filled up with drugs that was
shipping product out of here
in the beginning we probably had 30
artists in one time unfortunately now we
don't need as many people in the art
department because things are much
easier on the computer so you now are
doing only licensing right now what we
do is we do the artwork for a whole
bunch of other companies who are then
making it and shipping it I don't think
I ever want to be a manufacturer again
that takes away from Who I am and what I
really love to do is to do our work we
want to round out his face a little bit
so he looks a little cuter I've
obviously learned a ton over the years
but in terms of the artwork and the
process I would say that hasn't changed
at all
it was never about making money
it was about making good product and
having fun
dear journal it's me Doug I may not be
the president yeah
on Nickelodeon in the 90s I was the
voice of Doug funnie Roger Klotz Ren and
Stimpy what a decade I put a tiny little
bit of my own self into each character
give me a dog funny hi everybody this is
Doug funnie oh I got such a crush on
Patti mayonnaise I was pretty much like
that at 11 years old I used to fantasize
a lot you know I could entertain myself
for hours and what about Roger
hey you're the B's loser I ever saw oh
he was based on a bully that used to
bother me how about Ren will you shut up
you fool yes I should be you and Stimpy
hey Ren I picked the nose Goblin I
picked it myself for you you still
entertain yourself I'm sick of myself
you also do Futurama Philip J fry man
all's constant exposure to radiation is
making me thirsty shut up and take my
money I sounded just like that when I
was 25 I was all whiny nasally and if I
broke a string onstage you know it's
like ah man what am I to do now
and dr. Zoidberg young lady bring me a
sandwich from the dumpster and leave the
maggots on it I'm startling Professor
Farnsworth could use everyone I don't
want to live on this planet anymore that
Brannigan
she's a beautiful ship all right I'm
gonna fly her brains out good I'm very
fortunate really lucky that I can do
what I do and I just want to keep coming
to work till I tell you don't come in
anymore it is a final void ha goodbye
cause you probably remember this
prolific 90s fad but what you may not
know is that pogs have roots that go all
the way back to 17th century Japan okay
first things first let's review the
rules to play you start with the stack
of pogs all facedown player 1 take the
slammer and throws it down into the pile
and keeps any and all pogs at land
face-up pogs that remain facedown are
Rhys tact and the game continues on the
player with the most part at the end of
the game wins hooray
the origins of pogs can be traced back
to this menko a classic Japanese game
players threw cards at their opponent's
cards with the goal flipping them over
in the early 1900's Japanese immigrants
settled in Hawaii and brought the game
with them over time it evolved into a
version played with milk and juice caps
from a local dairy company in Maui
eventually renaming it pogs after their
juice that was made out of passion fruit
orange and guava get it in 1991 this
woman a sixth grade teacher named
blossom gal be so introduced the game to
her class her goal is to teach the math
but in a fun way and it worked
big time kids loved it and the game
exploded in popularity throughout Hawaii
and then spread to the mainland as the
game took off this marketing guy Alan
rip insky took note he purchased the
trademark for pogs founded the world POG
federation and got them into every store
in america and subsequently into nearly
every home with a 90's kid pause thanks
Alan
you
my mother swore to her dying days that
my first words were mama dad a resistor
capacitor I don't know if they had geeks
back then but I was probably one of them
there is a resurgence the 20 and
30-somethings have discovered analog
audio and they like it there is no
question that cassettes are making a
comeback we are in the last cassette
factory in the United States this
company duplicates audio cassettes and
loads blank audio cassettes
we're like a printing press they send us
the audio graphics if they won they
specify if they wanted in a box and we
put it all together national audio
company has been around since about 1968
69 when we first got into duplicating it
was mostly small runs the occasional
band to special order things and then
about four or five years ago there was a
sudden change
every GarageBand you can imagine showed
up at our doorstep wanting cassettes
2015 was probably our biggest year and
this year is without question on target
for exceeding analog brings a sense of
warmth that is not present in digital
download is so temporary and so passing
you know it's there and it's okay you
listen to it and you enjoy it but you
have nothing to go back and look at in
fact of holding it in your hands seems
to be one of the drawing cards for the
cassette and then for the older people
would be the nostalgia thing
I think the cassettes have made a
permanent return shouldn't have gone
away in the first place but they did and
now they're back my biggest concern is
to pass this on to somebody else yes
there's other people that know how to do
this most of them are my age so I need
to teach and train younger people I want
to see national audio continue for as
long as there are tapes to be made